those police who didn't go in to do  their jobs and their captain was telling  them not to go and the captain should be  fired or the people that didn't go and  there should be some kind of  accountability to be in there i'm not  talking about prison time but either  this is not a job for you because i  remember when we're in the military  there was an exercise we did we had to  low crawl and we're going through and  they're shooting it's late at night and  it's scary some guys couldn't handle it  they stood up  that's a perfect opportunity to tell  these guys military is not for you go  home some people are cops shouldn't be  cops some people are teachers shouldn't  be teachers there's many opportunities  when you notice you're just not meant to  be a teacher you don't have the patience  for kids you need to go find a different  job you're not meant to be a cop you  can't handle this kind of pressure go to  a different job